[Applause]
[Music]
happy
[Applause]
Wednesday so last night New Hampshire
clarified a few things for us first that
Donald Trump will probably be the
Republican nominee for
2024 all right true that's as much a
lock as President Biden making up a new
word we'll teach Donald Trump an
valuable lesson don't mess with the wom
Amer unless you want to get the
benefit wait what was that lesson
exactly don't give a microphone to
someone with
dementia the second lesson that Dana
Pina will never be welcome in New
Hampshire again Dana that was a water
fountain not a
bedet now somehow Nikki Haley came out
and gave a victory speech which is kind
of like the Hindenburg declaring victory
over
fire but wow she's doing like a speech
like she
won I said wow she's doing uh like a
speech like she won she didn't win she
lost this is not your typical victory
speech but let's not have somebody take
a victory when she had a very bad night
she had a very bad night a very bad
night and yet I can go up and I can say
that everybody oh thank you for the
victory I said I can go up and I can say
to everybody oh thank you for the
victory it's wonderful it's one or I can
go up and say who the hell was the
impostor that went up on the stage
before and like claimed a victory she
did very poorly actually it's true but
do you find in life you can't let people
get away
with I find in life you can't let people
get away with okay you can't you just
can't do
that and when I watched her in the fancy
dress that probably wasn't so
fancy come up I said what she doing we
won the dress not so fancy Trump carried
New Hampshire by double digits in a
state where more Democrats voted in the
Republican primary than Republicans did
that usually only happens in Chicago and
those voters are
dead it's not easy to lose badly in a
situation like that and then claim
victory she must be getting advice from
Liz
Cheney
o so what gives why would Nikki treat a
New Hampshire hammering like a win just
because she lost by less than expected
hell if Michael Jordan had that attitude
he wouldn't be in
Cooperstown I get it actually thank
you but it comes down to money and power
if she acts like she lost there goes the
gravy train and maybe she thinks if she
sticks around Trump might put her on the
ticket
after all when it comes to people Trump
will trash them then appoint them then
trash them again it's his thing one day
you're in the next day you're out I'm
the same way with my
Proctologist Now by some predictions
Nikki did better than expected although
after Iowa she could have showed up and
lit it and chill on fire and the media
would have said she did better than
expected the media says the same thing
when Biden doesn't poop his
pants but Trump's victory means the
deal's pretty much sealed and if we know
that Nikki knows that which is why as
primary day approached a new Nikki
emerged woke Nikki suddenly we're
hearing pandering anecdotes about Nikki
facing discrimination for being Brown
when she was growing up Nikki also
claimed that she was disqualified from a
beauty pageant when she was five cuz she
was neither black nor white but hey
that's happened to me too I also blamed
race when I didn't get the role for
Webster but it's part of the game you
pick a lane and hers was
identity we were the only Indian family
in our small southern town I was teased
every day for being Brown I get it I
also was teased for being brown but what
do you expect when you get 28 wedgies a
day
e but look I'm not questioning her
origin story or how it impacted her life
life all that sucks but when you're
pandering to the dams as a republican
it's kind of embarrassing so last night
her constituency wasn't really
Republicans it was Democrats in a way
she's running against her own party not
just Trump and now the Democratic
Primary in New Hampshire was also last
night and two little known Challengers
got roughly a quarter of the votes
between them there's Dean Phillips who
was so unknown even his wife and kids
asked to see his
ID Maran Williamson who has complet
completely transformed into a scented
candle yet they peeled 25% of the vote
away from the sitting president and hell
even Madonna after plastic surgery is
more recognizable than both of them
maybe it's because Biden didn't even go
to New Hampshire he was in Virginia
maybe he thought it was New Hampshire
and it was there that he said this hello
Virginia and the real Governor Terry
mcov yeah how's that for election denial
maybe someone should file articles of
impeachment right now I say he should go
to prison with the rest of the jant
Sixers but they've suffered enough
already so while the media contorts
itself to somehow make this a loss for
Trump and Nikki spends tens of millions
getting pummeled Biden appears weaker
frailer and frankly dead so when the
media tells you this thing is far from
over they're right the problem is
they're talking about the wrong
guy let's welcome tonight's guest when
he trips and falls he always lands on
his hair Fox News contributor Charlie
hurt even Governor hulas sorry he didn't
beat her former Congressman Lee
zeldon this cat has nine lives thanks to
being an expert at identity theft New
York Times bestselling author and fox
contributor
catp and he's an expert in MMA making
men afraid New York Times bestselling
author comedian and former NWA World T
Champion
ter Charlie I'm already sick of this
topic but we have to talk about it
because it's supposed to be important do
you think Nikki Haley is sticking around
because she's angling for VP or is that
ship sailed I don't know I mean his uh
Trump's comments about her a week or so
ago they were pretty shermanesque to
point where he what he said about he
said she wasn't presidential Timber and
then he followed It Up by saying the
fact that I said this means that you can
hold me to it and I can't undo it and
and if you think about it you know
whenever you have these discussions my
question always is okay what's the ad
that Democrats can run against them when
he picks her well it's going to be a
pretty devastating ad and we're not just
talking about the comments about the
dress but I think it's funny um I
thought his speech last night you know
everybody's been talking about how well
behaved Trump has been the last couple
of weeks and then last night uh he was
like he took the he took the chain off
and uh went after her uh I think because
she really I think she really ticked him
off yeah and he was not GNA and and and
of course you can't blame him I mean you
can't Trump the one thing everybody can
agree upon about Trump other than the
fact that he's highly entertaining and
hilarious is that if you poke him he's
coming after you yes exactly he will
will come back with a 100 pokes you
can't claim that you're a victim if you
poke him first yeah you know Lee KLA
Harris got the VP nod after basically
well literally calling Joe Biden a
racist remember that in the debate
saying I was that girl in the bus Joe
and then all of a sudden he's so I mean
it could happen here right this isn't
the Democratic party of 2020 which has
only gotten more woke since then yes KLA
Harris was able to elevate to the number
two position in the country following
this particular model of being the first
this the first that I don't think that
Donald Trump and choosing a vice
president is is looking for that above
Merit above where that person stands on
issues whether there's chemistry the
person's a hard hard worker the right
fit he's not looking to trade all of
those traits in by the way yesterday it
was a blowout amongst registered
Republicans I mean he crushed uh Nikki
Haley and I mean she should be getting
the hint here that it's time to step
aside allow us to unite if she really
cares about what's most important which
is saving this country about making sure
that Joe Biden doesn't get four more
years I mean she could do her part in a
really big Way by calling up president
Trump and say you're going to be the
nominee I cannot win any of the 50
states what can I do to help that phone
call needs to happen yesterday if it's
not going to happen yesterday it should
happen
tonight Lee
zeldon Lee zelden clearly angling for
VP CAD you're an astute Watcher of
primary politics you were up all night
watching this tabulating you actually
personally went to New Hampshire to
count them no I actually watch I did
watch it yes I texted Dana I was like
how are you alive she was on all day oh
no this is going to be the year for the
libertarian
[Laughter]
just kidding guys I know it never it
never is our year uh but I that's you
know that that's what I believe um Nikki
Haley I think it's interesting how she's
trying to make appeals to people you
know growing up I was bullied like I was
bullied also growing up you know and I
didn't grow up to love war
[Laughter]
yeah excellent point from the
libertarian yeah yes what were you
bullied over no being
myself were you ever kind of on me yeah
were you ever disqualified from a beauty
pageant I would never go near a beauty
pageant you know you know what I I was a
very androgynous looking child yeah but
the more important question did your
parents ever enroll you in a segregated
Beauty I'm very confused where the yeah
I didn't really understand what what was
this pageant was it like it was it in a
Marriott like where was it apparently it
was in like the the' 40s yeah it had she
was F she's 50 something so it had to be
the late 70s Tyrus well to be fair okay
in the 70s it was still illegal in some
states my home state of Boston
Massachusetts for the for the blacks to
marry the whites yeah so I guess when
she went to the world's racist beauty
pageant um she was a little too confused
and she insulted the racist judges which
is hard to do yeah especially at five
yeah so here's the here's the issue I
have I don't let's just say for argument
sakes that all those things that she
said happened MH all that only further
makes your journey to be able to run for
president in the United States greater
because you overcame obstacles but
that's not the speech she's making
because I would support that be like yep
they called me Brown every day but guess
what now they might call me Madam
president that's a great story and
that's people who have used something
because everyone in this audience has
got a story you we all have a story it
doesn't matter what color what somebody
didn't like you for some reason but
she's not doing that she's she's plating
to who's writing the script now do you
know what she's doing she was
differentiating herself from other
Republicans saying I'm not racist like
they are yeah which is crazy seeing how
the most straight up Let The Best Man
Woman win regardless of color is being
shown at the highest level in the
Republican Party MH we had two brown
people good thing V didn't show up at
that beauty pageant it would been
you imagine the look on the racist black
guys and white guys like someone want to
explain to me how two brownies got in
here it's so fun I wonder if she ever
brought that up while the was around no
because whenever you know it's funny
because the brown on Brown hate was
pretty solid between V and Nikki that's
true like she just the look of him
disgusted her she called them scum she
literally was behaving like the racist
black and white organization to let her
compete so you have to be careful that
you don't become what you hate because
whenever Viet came in the room she's
like I hate that brown so we just have
to be careful it's so funny though she
did call him she call him scum it was
like Asian on Asian hate crime it he's
Korean he's not Chinese you know so it's
like wow so true hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else